nos encontramos dentro de la llamada
zona verde
debatado el grinson o así lo llamaron
los norteamericanos después de esa
invasión de 2003 realmente aquí antes se
encontraban los palacios la sede de
gobierno de Sadam husein y nos
encontramos en uno de esos lugares
míticos de lo que fue durante su
dictadura a nuestra espalda están estas
dos espadas cruzadas con sus manos que
construyó durante esa guerra contra Irán
que duró ocho años en la década de los
80 y que es una de las guerras más
sangrientas después de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial detrás nuestro Allí se ve el
escenario donde él se ponía se escondía
detrás de algunas de esos vidrios toda
la gente de su dictadura se ponía allí y
aquí hacían las paradas militares al
otro extremo está Otra de esas arcos con
esas espadas parte de esa grandeza de
que quiso imponer Sadam husein
especialmente después de esa guerra
realmente ninguno de los dos países
salió victorioso de hecho Irak fue quien
invadió a Irán muy poco después de la
victoria de la Revolución en 1979
alcanzaron a tomar un control de cierta
parte del Sur del país en la región del
juztán pero los iraníes apunta de
hombres muchos de ellos niños lograron
recuperar esta región ninguno como digo
fue victorioso pero sadán lo quiso
demostrar como uno de sus golpes de
fuerza en uno de esas tantas
manifestaciones de grandeza que tenía
aquel dictador